]
>> HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> ARE YOU HAPPY TO LIVE IN A
FREE STATE?
ARE YOU ALL GOING TO GO OUT ON
NOVEMBER 8th SO WE CAN
KEEP IT A FREE STATE?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND WILL YOU HELP ME ONCE AND
FOR ALL SEND A TIRED, WORN-OUT
OLD DONKEY BACK TO PASTURE?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: VERY LOW ENERGY
CROWD I CAN SEE TONIGHT.
GOVERNOR, GREAT TO SEE YOU, UM -
>> BUT THIS ENERGY SHOWS YOU
-- AND I THINK YOU AND I AGREE
ON THIS -- THE RED WAVE IN
2022 STARTS IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE ARE GOING TO LAUNCH IT.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU?
THESE POLLS COMING OUT
TONIGHT, I MENTIONED HERSCHEL
UP BY FIVE.
YESTERDAY HE WAS 2.5.
TODAY HE'S UP BY FIVE.
OZ NOW UP BY THREE.
CARRIE LAKE FROM UP BY FIVE
AND NOW UP BY 11.
MASTERS IS ABOUT TO TAKE KELLY
IN THE STATE OF ARIZONA.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I THINK WE'RE GOING TO WIN
ALL OF THOSE RACES.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO WIN
MANY MORE BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE VOTERS ARE
RESPONDING TO A FAILED
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE'S JUST NO WAY TO SUGAR
COAT IT.
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN WORSE SINCE
JOE BIDEN WAS PRESIDENT.
THE INFLATION'S AT A 40-YEAR
HIGH.
HE'S WAGED WAR ON AMERICAN
ENERGY.
HE'S BUNGLED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER LIKE WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
SO ON ISSUE AFTER ISSUE,
THEY'RE FAILING.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL IN
LOCK STEP WITH HIM.
THEY WILL NOT BREAK WITH THEIR
EXTREME POLICIES AND OUR
CANDIDATES ARE OFFERING A
BETTER VISION.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO WORK
HARD OVER THESE NEXT LITTLE
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE GOING
OUT TO VOTE SO IF WE DO OUR
PART AND GET ALL LIKE-MINDED
PEOPLE -- AND NOT JUST
REPUBLICANS, WE HAVE
INDEPENDENTS AND SOME
DEMOCRATS AS WELL -- IF WE ALL
DO THAT, I THINK THIS'LL BE
ONE OF OUR BEST MID-TERM
ELECTIONS OF OUR LIFETIME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: I HOPE YOU'RE
RIGHT.
WE KNOW USA TODAY'S SUFFOLK
POLL CAME OUT AND THE 16% OF
PREVIOUSLY UNDECIDED PEOPLE,
THEY SAID ALMOST ALL OF THEM
ARE BREAKING LAST-MINUTE
TOWARDS THE G.O.P.
YOU KNOW,
HERE JOE BIDEN BECOMES
PRESIDENT.
41-YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION.
RECORD-HIGH GAS PRICES.
WIDE-OPEN BORDERS.
ABANDONING ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
ALL OF THESE -- NO LAW AND
ORDER.
NO BAIL.
DEFUND.
DISMANTLE POLICE OFFICERS.
WOKE EDUCATION VERSUS
TRADITIONAL EDUCATION.
HOW'D IT GO SO BAD IN 20
MONTHS?
>> SO I DON'T KNOW THAT I'VE
EVER SEEN IT THIS BAD IN OUR
COUNTRY SINCE I'VE BEEN
AROUND, BUT THE THING THAT
STRIKES ME ABOUT THIS IS THAT
ALL OF THOSE PROBLEMS YOU SAID
ARE CREATED AND MANUFACTURED
BY BIDEN HIMSELF WITH HIS BAD
POLICY.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SOMETIMES --
THERE'S SOMETIMES THINGS THAT
HAPPEN WITH THE ECONOMY,
SOMETIMES ENERGY PRICES GO UP
BECAUSE OF GLOBAL SPIKE BUT
NOW HE'S WAGING WAR ON OUR OWN
ABILITY TO PRODUCE.
HE'S BEGGING MODURO FOR
ENERGY.
HE'S BEGGING THE SAUDIS FOR
THE SAUDIS CUT PRODUCTION.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THEY'RE
DOING POLITICS AGAINST BIDEN.
YEAH, I THINK THEY PROBABLY
ARE, BUT HE PUT HIMSELF IN
THIS POSITION BY MAKING OUR
COUNTRY VULNERABLE TO THIS.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU THINK
WHEN THE SAUDIS REVEALED THAT
JOE BIDEN REJECTED HIS REQUEST
HE WOULD INCREASE PRODUCTION,
HE WAS TOLD THEY WOULD
DECREASE IT.
HE SAID, OK, CAN YOU WAIT TO
ANNOUNCE IT FOR A MONTH UNTIL
AFTER THE MIDTERM.
IF THAT WAS A GUY WITH THE
LAST NAME TRUMP OR DESANTIS,
WOULDN'T THAT BE CALLED
COLLUSION?
>> LITERALLY, HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN IMPEACHED IF THE DEMOCRAT
STANDARD APPLIED TO HIM.
THEY IMPEACHED TRUMP BASED ON
A PHONE CALL MADE TO UKRAINE.
>> Sean: THE PHONE CALL WAS
DON'T MISMANAGE OUR MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS ABOUT.
>> THERE WAS MISMANAGEMENT.
THERE'S VALID CONCERN THAT HE
HAD.
>> Sean: I'M ON THE EAST
COAST NOW BUT I LIVED IN
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA FOR A WHILE
-- I DON'T LIVE ON THE EAST
COAST FULL-TIME.
I'M MOVING.
AND I WILL NOT VOTE LIKE THE
AVERAGE NEW YORKER, I'LL TELL
YOU THERE.
>> I TOLD SEAN BEFORE BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN BUGGING HIM ABOUT
DOING THIS FOR YEARS.
I SAID WHY DON'T YOU COME
WHERE YOUR VOTE COUNTS?
NEW YORK, I THINK WE'LL ELECT
A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR, AND
YOU'LL BE HELPING IN THAT.
>> IT PROBABLY IS THE LAST
CHANCE NEW YORK HAS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE OF MY GRADING
DO YOU KNOW EVERY DAY?
DO YOU HAVE AN AVERAGE?
BECAUSE I'VE READ ABOUT 800.
>> I THINK BETWEEN 800 AND
11:00.
WE'VE LED THE COUNTRY IN NET
IN MIGRATION SINCE COVID IN A
COUNTRY MILE.
WE'VE HAD MORE ADJUSTED GROSS
INCOME MOVE INTO THIS STATE
SINCE COVID THAN EVER MOVED
INTO OUR STATE IN OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY IN A SAME
TIME PERIOD.
I KNOW PEOPLE WILL ASK, HEY F
SOMEONE IS COMING FROM A DEEP
BLUE STATE WILL THEY VOTE THE
SAME WAY TO BRING THE POLICIES
HERE?
WELL, WHEN I WAS GOVERNOR,
300,000 MORE DEMOCRATS IN
FLORIDA THAN REPUBLICANS.
TODAY, WE HAVE 306,000 MORE
REGISTERED REPUBLICANS THAN
DEMOCRATS.
>> I WAS TALKING TO THE
AUDIENCE BEFORE YOU CAME OUT.
TO ME, RONALD REGAN
CONSERVATIVE WORKS, MAGA
CONSERVATIVE WORKS.
I DON'T LIKE TO CALL MYSELF A
CONSERVATIVE FOR NO REASON BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE LOWER
TAXES, WHEN YOU BELIEVE IN
CAPITALISM, WHEN YOU CONTROL
YOUR BORDERS, WHEN YOU'RE
ENERGY-INDEPENDENT, YOU'RE THE
MASTER OF YOUR OWN DESTINY.
WHY DID WE EVER ABANDON WHAT
WAS WORKING?
>> I THINK ALSO WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THE LEFT HAS
GONE SO OFF THEIR ROCKER THAT
IF YOU JUST SO SOME COMMON
SENSE, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
VERY FAR WITH A LOT OF VOTERS.
WHO RELEASES CRIMINALS BACK ON
THE STREET KNOWING THEY'RE
GOING TO COMMIT MORE CRIMES
AGAIN?
WHAT KIND OF A PROSECUTOR --
>> Sean: JOHN FETTERMAN?
>> YES.
WHAT KIND OF A PROSECUTOR
WOULD SAY, YOU CAN STEAL $900
WORTH OF MERCHANDISE, JUST
DON'T STEAL $1,000 AND WE
WON'T EVER PROSECUTE YOU.
YOU SEE A LOT OF THE CITIES
HAVE REALLY GONE INTO
DISREBUKE BECAUSE OF THESE
REALLY BAD POLICIES SO WE'RE
JUST DOING BASIC COMMONSENSE
TRIED AND TRUE AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE MOST
TALKED-ABOUT DECISIONS YOU
MADE, YOU HAD 50 OR 52 PEOPLE
THAT THEY SIGNED A CONSENT
FORM THAT THEY WANTED TO GO TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A
SANCTUARY ISLAND.
OK.
YOU'RE KIND ENOUGH TO
TRANSPORT THEM TO THEIR
SANCTUARY ISLAND.
HOW IS IT THAT THE SANCTUARY
OR SANCTIMONIOUS LEFTIST THREW
THEM OFF THE ISLAND IN LESS
THAN 24 HOURS?
>> I MEAN, AND NOT ONLY THAT,
THEY HAVE A SOCIAL SERVICES
OFFICE THERE THAT SAYS, YOU
KNOW, EVERYBODY IS WELCOME.
REFUGEES WELCOME, ALL THIS
OTHER STUFF.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE
ADVERTISING.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHAT THEY
SAID.
>> I THINK WHAT IT SHOWED IS
THIS, THE ELITES IN OUR
COUNTRY, THEY WANT TO IMPOSE
POLICIES ON ALL OF US, BUT
THEY DO NOT WANT TO HAVE TO
FACE THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR
OWN POLICIES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT SHOWS.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, GOVERNOR
DESANTIS WHO WILL BE WITH US
FOR THE HOUR WE RETURN NOW TO
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL ADS
OF THE YEAR.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AD RUN BY
GOVERNOR DESANTIS' CAMPAIGN.
>> I GET ASKED ALL THE TIME,
WHO IS RON DESANTIS?
WELL, HE'S THE KID WHO GREW UP
RIGHT HERE IN FLORIDA WORKING
HIS TAIL OFF, PAYING HIS OWN
WAY THROUGH SCHOOL AND THEN
VOLUNTEERING TO SERVE IN THE
NAVY AND DEPLOYING TO IRAQ.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO RON
DESANTIS REALLY IS, WHEN I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER AND I
WAS FACING THE BATTLE FOR MY
LIFE, HE WAS THE DAD WHO TOOK
CARE OF MY CHILDREN WHEN I
COULDN'T.
HE WAS THERE TO PICK ME OFF OF
THE GROUND WHEN I LITERALLY
COULD NOT STAND.
>> Sean: LET'S GIVE A WARM
FLORIDA WELCOME TO THE FIRST
LADY OF FLORIDA, CASEY
DESANTIS IS HERE WITH US
TONIGHT.
>> Sean: WELCOME.
SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
>> JUAN 100% CANCER-FREE?
-- 100% CANCER-FREE?
>> 100% CANCER-FREE TO THE
THANKS OF GOD.
>> Sean: MY MOM HAD STAGE 4,
19 LYMPH NODES, LOST ALL HER
HAIR, DOUBLE MASTECTOMY,
RADIATION, IT'S TERRIFYING
WHEN YOU HEAR CANCER.
>> THAT'S THE FIRST TIME I SAW
THAT AD.
I HAD NOT SEEN THAT AD SINCE I
SHOT IT.
WHEN I DID IT, I ASKED
EVERYONE KINDLY TO LEAVE THE
ROOM BECAUSE I WANTED TO LOOK
INTO THE CAMERA AND TELL
EVERYONE EXACTLY WHO RON
DESANTIS IS BECAUSE WHEN I
WENT THROUGH ONE OF THE
HARDEST THINGS I EVER WENT
THROUGH IN MY LIFE, I HAD A
GUY WHO WAS WITH ME EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY TO LITERALLY PICK
ME UP OFF OF THE GROUND.
HE WASN'T JUST THERE FOR ME,
HE WAS THERE FOR MY KIDS.
IMAGINE AS A MOM OF THREE
LITTLE BABIES WHEN YOU CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF YOUR KIDS AND PUT
THEM TO BED BUT YOU GOT
SOMEBODY LIKE THIS HELPING YOU
OUT, IT MEANS THE WORLD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: WE'RE SO GLAD
YOU'RE WELL.
UM, POLITICS IS A
ROUGH-AND-TUMBLE BUSINESS.
>> YOU DON'T SAY?
>> Sean: I DO.
WE CALL IT A BLOOD SPORT.
YOU SEE THE TOUGH SIDE OF IT.
AND THEN YOU SEE WHEN YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL YOU SEE THE UP SIDE
OF IT.
HOW HARD IS IT ON YOU WHEN YOU
HEAR HIM BEING ATTACKED?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T EVEN PAY ANY ATTENTION
TO IT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE BUY WHAT THE WOKE
CORPORATE MEDIA IS THROWING AT
THEM ANYMORE.
I THINK THEY KNOW THE TRUTH
THEM SAW A GUY IN RON DESANTIS
WHO STOOD UP FOR THE RIGHTS OF
THE PEOPLE OF THIS STATE AND
STOOD UP FOR FREEDOM AND
THEY'RE SO PROUD FOR
EVERYTHING THAT HE'S DONE.
HE WAS RIGHT THROUGH COVID.
A LOT OF THE MEDIA WHO WERE
WRONG NEVER APOLOGIZED FOR
BEING WRONG AND SO WRONG.
I THINK THEY'RE PROUD OF RON.
I DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO
ANYTHING THEY SAY TO BE
BRUTALLY HONEST WITH YOU.
>> Sean: YOU'VE ALSO BOTH
BEEN VERY ACTIVE AND INVOLVED
-- I LIVED IN SOUTHWEST
FLORIDA.
HOW'S THE HURRICANE -- SANIBEL
ISLAND WAS DESTROYED.
I SAW THE COAST OF FT. MYERS.
I WAS SHOCKED!
>> I MEAN IT WAS OBVIOUSLY A
DEVASTATING STORM THAT DID A
LOT OF DAMAGE, BUT I'LL TELL
YOU THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN
RAPID.
WE HAD SEARCH AND RESCUE EVEN
WHEN THE TROPICAL STORM WINDS
WERE STILL BLOWING IN THERE
HELPING ALL THE FOLKS.
THEY DID OVER 3,000 RESCUE
MISSIONS.
THE QUICKEST POWER RESTORATION
WE HAD IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA
FOR MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OUT BUT
YOU HAD THE ISLANDS SEVERED
FROM THE MAINLAND.
PEOPLE CAME TO ME.
THEY WEREN'T STATE BRIDGES BUT
THEY SAID GOVERNOR, CAN YOU
HELP?
I SAID LET'S HELP.
WE DID ONE BRIDGE TO PINE
ISLAND IN THREE DAYS.
WE DID --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THEN WE DID THE SANIBEL
CAUSEWAY WHICH WAS SEVERED IN
THREE PLACES.
WE DID THAT.
THAT OPENED TO THE PUBLIC
THREE WEEKS FROM THE DAY THAT
THE HURRICANE CAME THROUGH.
>> Sean: I'M ON A HARD
BREAK.
WE HAVE TO TAKE A BREAK.
FIRST LADY